so I'm not really sure how to introduce
this but you all know what this is so
first question
any advice for public university
administrators who do not have tenure
who have been asked to participate in
equity and diversity conversations or
committees and who want to speak out
against post-modernism intersectional
ISM and authoritarianism but are
inhibited from doing so due to
cultivated insecurities Ilias star asks
us that question well the first thing
you want to make sure is that you know
you prepare yourself for that right you
because otherwise you'll get afraid and
so you this is something to know for you
younger people to like you want to put
yourself in a situation in your life
where you have options when you have to
make moral decisions and so sometimes
that means keeping your resume sharp and
clean and making sure that if you needed
to make a lateral move in your
profession that you could probably do it
because otherwise you end up in slave to
your insecurities let's say and that you
really want to think about that because
you want to set yourself up in your life
so that to the degree that it's possible
you can you can say what your conscience
demands that you say for the
administrators I would say don't
underestimate the number of people that
agree with you there's likely far more
than who disagree with you but they're
just as worried as you are about
speaking up and they often don't hold
the positions of power because they're
off doing useful and important things
instead of worrying about like imposing
political politically correct idiocy on
everyone else but there's more people
out there like you than you think and
you'll be giving voice to what's almost
inevitably the silent minority and then
the last thing I would say is if you're
gonna oppose unconscious bias training
then you need to go online and
familiarize yourself with relevant
literature to the degree that you can so
that you know way more than the
people that you're talking to and then
advance with caution and don't make
unnecessary enemies and that's that's
pretty much all I can say about that
yeah I guess I would maybe add a couple
things I think Jordan is right that the
it's not even necessarily silent support
but it's non public support is immense
and things are a little different for an
administrator administrators are in a
position to serve their own interests as
they betray their colleges professors
are in a different spot my feeling for
professors in this situation is that if
they serve their own interests by not
speaking up in the short term then they
end up living under the regimes that get
set up and chances are if you're feeling
really uncomfortable about a policy
initiative that is moving down the pike
eventually it's going to target you so
it isn't really a question of whether or
not to stand up it's a question of
whether to stand up now or later and now
is almost certainly the better choice
there is also an issue though of
organizing in a way that academics are
not good at academics need to be able to
gather when something is moving through
a governance structure you need to be
able to gather with other reasonable
people and plot a course and the very
best thing that you can do is figure out
how to protect each other one is almost
never in a good position to defend
themselves but if you stand up and
defend somebody else you have a lot more
leeway so one of the things that serves
these these movements is the fact that
people have to defend themselves and
they're compromised in so doing if
people can agree to protect each other
and stand up in numbers they will be
much harder to defeat and so figure out
how to gather privately and talk about
what's actually taking place and you
know amp up each other's courage I've
found YouTube presentations of stefan
molyneux and others on our case
selection theory and the tendencies of
liberals and conservatives fascinating
and troubling as much explanatory value
as there may be in
looking at politics through the lens of
the to survival reproductive strategies
in nature it could easily be twisted by
lesser thinkers into justification for
other izing political opponents in terms
of predators and prey
humans are not lions and rabbits but our
case selection theory may provide some
understanding of how the cyclic rise and
fall of civilisation unfolds how close
to the truth is it that has common
values like free speech unravel genes
and environment takeover polarizing
groups into conflict and how meaningful
how can meaningful common ground be
created to avoid a catastrophe of
unconscious social processes
I guess that's targeted at me I have to
say I have not seen Mali news videos on
this so I have no idea what the
hypothesis that's being advanced is I
will say that people do not appreciate
the extent to which we have not escaped
our evolutionary nature people tend to
think that evolution is what created us
but that it is not an important factor
in our current circumstance and nothing
could be farther from the truth
we do live under novel circumstances for
which we are not evolutionarily prepared
but the toolkit that we bring to the
table is thoroughly evolutionary which
means that our reactions to things have
everything to do with a program that is
not well understood by most people once
you realize what it is that evolution
has set us in motion to do a good person
will have no choice but to reject it
it's not an honorable program it is no
different than the program that drives a
liver fluke or malaria or a spruce tree
the the evolutionary program has an
objective and it is singular and that is
to produce more copies of the genome in
question having freed yourself from
obligation to that program understanding
what kinds of dynamics have allowed
human populations to move from one
opportunity to the next is vitally
important because if you look at our
current situation you will realize that
we stand at a precipice we have
ancestral wisdom that has been generated
by evolutionary processes and it is
completely inadequate
to the problems that we face we have to
generate new wisdom and that is
something that many ancestors have also
had to do we have to resist therefore
those tendencies that derail that
process those tendencies that make us
unable to talk to each other candidly
about what's going on so that we can
access the toolkit that allows human
populations to bootstrap a new mechanism
for being that is the place in history
we are the only difference between this
one and all of the predecessors that
looked like it is this time we are all
in it together the way we have rigged
civilization technologically means that
our fates are now linked across the
globe and we have to put aside our
differences if we're to survive another
hundred years I'd like to add something
to that it's probably a point on which
we disagree slightly I mean I certainly
don't disagree with Brits supposition
that were driven by evolutionarily
determined factors to a degree that
people don't appreciate I mean we don't
appreciate our own biology because it's
so complex we can't understand it so
it's not it's not that surprising but
I'm I'm less pessimistic than say
Richard Dawkins about the relationship
between the genome and and actually
manifest behavior because think about it
this way one of the things that men are
adapted to is the existence of the male
competency hierarchy and I call it a
competency hierarchy because I think
dominance hierarchy is the wrong word
because it's been around for a very very
very long period of time like you can
trace hierarchical structures governing
animal behavior back about a third of
the billion years so it's it's older
than trees and what happens is that the
males at the top of the competence
hierarchy are much more likely to leave
progeny and the other men basically vote
for them because men in functional
societies organize themselves into
competence hierarchies and so I actually
think that men are driven at least in
part by the desire to emulate the
pattern of behavior that moves them up
competence hierarchies because that's
what makes them attractive to females
and that's what increases the
probability that they'll leave offspring
so I actually think that genetic
structures and the moral structures act
much more in accordance with one another
than
people like Dawkins and apparently
people like Brett assume so you know
well so that's what I have to say can I
can I just respond a little bit what I
would say is I don't disagree with that
formulation I think that our cultural
apparatus and our genomes are actually
built to function together in a
particular way and that we are built to
solve these problems by various
mechanisms my concern is that the
novelty of this moment in history due to
technology and and other factors is
going to interrupt the processes that
would normally solve this problem that
would allow us to bootstrap our way out
of it so my pessimism is not about the
human capacity to do this or even the
human instinct to do it my pessimism is
about the fact that the proper mode is
not going to be triggered in time what
advice would you have to improve ones
conscientiousness for people with
attention deficit or similar disorders
which directly interfere with this trait
anything other than schedules / routines
anything other than scheduling well I
mean in order to focus your attention
you have to have your emotions aligned
because otherwise it'll fragment and you
know ADHD is a loose diagnosis you might
want to take an online personality test
to find out if you have ADHD or if
you're just really high in openness and
extraversion and low in the other three
traits because it's not a pathological
condition it's just a temperamental
variation like creative people tend to
think laterally and and and they're
somewhat scattered and extroverted
people are somewhat impulsive so if
you're extroverted and open and you're
not very conscientious and you're not
very agreeable you're gonna manifest
yourself as somewhat attention deficit
disorder it's not necessarily a
pathology and the fact that ADHD
medication works for you is no
indication of the validity of the
diagnosis because ADHD medication makes
everyone concentrate more it doesn't
have a paradoxical calming effect on
people with ADHD
it's complete nonsense so one of the
things I would recommend this is partly
why we built the future authoring
program is make a bloody plan and make
sure the plan includes two things where
you want to be in three to five years
and how to get there and where you do
not want to be in three to five years
and you need to really think that
through like and make both of those
things potential realities and then your
emotions will align with your goals and
increase the probability that the
unconscious mechanisms that direct your
attention will stay on task and focused
and then the other thing I would say is
learn to use a schedule but don't treat
it like a tyrant that's the mistake
people make with with schedules a
schedule is not a tyrant what you're
using the schedule for is to design the
days that you would like to have if your
life was optimized and so it's actually
a friend it's the discipline equals
freedom thing that the jakka willing
talks about you know if you learn to
manage your time you actually have way
more time not less you have way more
freedom not less and it might take you
two years to get good at using a
schedule and following it so specify
your aims and your counter aims and and
and and organize your use of time and
and just practice that you'll get better
at it you can discipline yourself it
takes a little while but but you can
learn to do it I would add something to
that as well which is that I think we
don't really understand what human
emotions are for we sort of treat them
as an anomaly that are untrustworthy
because they don't necessarily make
sense in analytical terms and really
that whole system of emotions that
actually dominates most of our living
experience is a system to program us to
function better so with respect to
something like ADHD I have to agree I'm
not a huge fan of this diagnosis it
seems to me that it results from the
fact that we're living under
circumstances that caused some of us
trouble rather than the fact that we're
actually broken in some way but what
that suggests is that the answer to the
question of how
to become more conscientious if you're
not sufficiently conscientious is to put
yourself in circumstances where
conscientiousness is helpful to you and
if you do that if you seek out those
circumstances then when you fail to be
conscientious it will generate psychic
pain that psychic pain will cause you to
de-emphasize the patterns that got you
into trouble when you do it right you'll
feel pleasure that will cause those
systems to be elaborated and suddenly
you'll be more conscientious do you
believe we are experiencing a Christian
Renaissance I have no idea I mean all I
can I can all I can account to is my own
experience in this in this field I know
that for the past year I've been taking
on this crazy journey that I didn't
expect at all and by now I'm getting
emails every day and the emails are
basically the the PI there's a pattern
that emails are the same and it's I have
a vague religious upbringing and became
an atheist Sam Harris style in college
discovered Jordan Peterson realized
religion isn't stupid discovered your
videos and thought wow okay and now like
I want to go to church and it's like I
don't know I have no idea like I don't
know what numbers those represent like I
don't know how many people write me and
how many people who are going through
that don't write me but for sure as a
person I believe that to dive back I
mean that my stake my entire life on
this being an icon carver and talking
about the things that I've talked about
tonight are completely related together
I believe that the the underlying
grammar that was developed in
Christianity especially in the first
1000 years the underlying relationships
of symbols is like an algebra and it and
it's it's like a mesh through which we
can look at the world and I think that
to recover that to the extent that it's
possible is one of the solutions out of
our morass and so I've staked my own
yeah my life on that so
yeah yeah well I mean it was a surprise
to me when I learned say 30 years ago
that our cognitive architecture and our
perceptual architecture were grounded in
this grammar that Jonathan referred to
and that there's no escaping from it you
can either understand it or not
understand it if you don't understand it
you live as a mess of internal
contradictions and that that paralyzes
you in many ways
you're a house divided within itself
these archetypal stories let's say
Christian or not but certainly they're
Christian insofar as the West is
predicated the West is a society
predicated on those stories they're
they're inescapable and of ultimate
value they're that because they lay out
the patterns this is actually the point
of them they lay out the pattern of
being that enables you to maintain
nobility and sanity in the face of
suffering and evil now if you don't
believe in suffering you're evil then
while you don't have a problem but
you're not very bright if you don't
believe in those two things I mean
you're just like you're naive beyond
belief
and you need an antidote to to those
forces because they'll tear you apart
and the question is is there an antidote
and then and the answer is well there's
a best path forward anyways and the idea
that the best path forward has something
to do with shouldering your cross and
taking responsibility for your own
malevolence is there isn't a better
answer that anyone has ever come up with
than that so now are we experiencing a
Christian Renaissance I have the same
feeling as Jonathan who who then who
knows like more than a year ago I should
probably let you go on here so I don't
say what I'm about to say we're just
gonna get me in a lot of trouble I have
a feeling but maybe we're going through
a
Christian Renaissance but we shouldn't
it's not a good idea and that is not to
say that there are not a tremendous
number of values to be rescued from
Christianity as there are from any
ancient tradition that has survived into
the present however I would say if
there's one thing I'm convinced of as an
evolutionary biologist who has been very
focused on human beings it is that there
is no ideology that we can pull off the
shelf that is adequate to our present
circumstances so whatever it is it's
gonna be a 3.0 or a 4.0 version it's not
going to be the version that we have
available to us now and that is that is
not to argue that the versions that we
have now are not wisdom from a past era
they just simply aren't up to the
challenge you know I gotta say dr.
Weinstein during your talk you come to
this event put on my libertarians and
you say both left and right libertarians
are wrong and then you go up on a stage
with an orthodox iconographer and say we
should not experience the Christian
Renaissance and I kind of feel like you
just want to get into a fight all right
Thomas Lindner wants to know are you
familiar with Darmok and Jalad at
Tanagra and oh yeah and if so will we
see Chaka when the walls fell
universally none of you all man do but
so in the Star Trek The Next Generation
oh yes okay Patrick Stewart gets
stranded on a planet with an alien who
looks suspiciously human which is weird
how that works and this alien can only
speak in metaphors and stories so he for
example says Darmok and Jalad at Tanagra
which is like this famous bow or two
guys to come together to defeat evil and
he keeps trying to say this to Patrick
Stewart and he doesn't know what the
hell he's saying because yes but from
the 90s man so essentially he has to
learn to communicate with of being a
species of beings that can only
speak through story and metaphor and
analogy based in their own history and
their own myths and their own symbols so
thomas Lindner rightly thought this
would be an excellent question to ask
and i'm sure he's very disappointed that
none of you watch Star Trek I am as well
[Laughter]
too drawn Peterson I wanted to ask you
about psychopaths and mythology
mythology is a conscious outgrowth of
our underlying cognitive structure
accumulated over history that teaches us
how to live people who score very high
in psychopathy have measurable
differences in brain structures linked
to cognition and affect leading to high
charisma no empathy remorse and lower
impulse control
I was wondering how these differences
influenced their sense of relief
influenced their sense of religion
mythology and if so could Marxism Nazism
and other pathological ideologies and
religious sects represent an attempt by
Psychopaths to create their own
mythology and erase the history and
culture of empathic humans in brackets I
realized that psychopathy / pathology
are on a continuum is asked by Michael
goodwill I don't think that we really
understand the neurological differences
between Psychopaths and normal people
very well I know the literature pretty
well so it isn't obvious to me that
Psychopaths are qualitatively different
I don't think that we formulate the
question properly I think that the
person who appears psychopathic is
likely very low in agreeableness which
does increase the probability that
you'll end up in prison and very low in
conscientiousness and then the other
traits very the charismatic type of
psychopath generally would be also very
high in extraversion so I think it's a
normal although rare temperamental
variant I also am not convinced that
there are people who are born
psychopathic I think it's a I think
there are children who are born who are
very very tough and aggressive and
difficult to socialize
and that some percentage of them become
psychopathic so I'm not convinced that
it's genetically determined in its
entirety having said that I mean there
are very aggressive people who are
deceitful who use manipulation to move
forward the question is what role do
they play in the formulation of
political movements or belief systems
well I don't I don't think we know the
answer to that the only thing I could
say is that the sort of person and these
might not necessarily be the psychopaths
the sort of person who wants mayhem are
going to gravitate towards extreme
political what extreme those who profess
extreme political beliefs because the
probability that violence will erupt is
higher and there's certainly no shortage
of people who would rather that violence
erupted that's actually one of the
reasons that the current situation is so
complex you know among the anti-fatigue
sand among the radical right-wingers
there are people who are praying for
violence because that's actually their
natural milieu or maybe they're
resentful and hoping for destruction but
I'm not sure that you can draw a line in
a simple manner between that and
psychopathy per se
I mean Psychopaths generally aren't
group oriented right they're they're
more individual predator types and maybe
they can find a niche within an
organization but it's it's not exactly
it's not exactly their normal hangout I
would say for Jonathan or Jordan or
Brett it's often said that the fight
against evil only makes it stronger by
adding fuel to the fire but sometimes it
seems imperative to openly engage in
opposition to or at least draw attention
to a subject in order to dismantle it
how have you decided when to speak out
against things versus simply being an
advocate for the things you value and
love I have no idea
I think I mean I'd like in my case I've
just it's just been circumstance where I
felt like all of a sudden I was in a
place where people were listening to me
and so I said things but I don't know
when that should be for a person like I
until now I've never had any public
persona and so I have not figured that
out at all yet got a longer public
persona though well for me it was when I
knew that the cost of not saying
something was higher than the cost of
saying something because one of the
things I do in my clinical practice and
this is something that you can practice
as a as a habit of thought like what
happens to people is that if they're in
a routine they discount the danger of
the routine now often that's
intelligence because if intelligent
because if you're in a routine and
nothing terrible is happening then it
looks like the routine isn't very risky
so it's not surprising that you stop
being afraid of those things that you've
routinized but let's say you're bored to
death in your job so and you're thinking
well should I take the risk of leaving
my job it's the wrong question the right
question is there's a risk in continuing
with my job because I'm bored stiff and
I'm getting resentful and I'm not
working very effectively and there's a
risk associated with leaving my job and
which of those two risks would I rather
take that's a way better way of thinking
about it and so if you're deciding to
speak out you do the same thing you
think well okay which there's risk both
ways which of these would I rather live
with and you know I'm was very sensitive
or am very sensitive maybe even very
oversensitive to the risks associated
with the suppression of free speech
because you know I don't know for with
certainty how large a social risk were
taking right now with the moves
especially on the radical left to
delimit people's ability to speak and
think freely like maybe it's a tempest
in a teapot that's that's certainly been
an accusation that's been leveled at me
but for me personally it was that it was
very personal in some sense which was
that I
guard the ability to choose my own words
under every circumstance I would say as
of crucial importance and so when
legislation was afoot in Canada to
infringe upon that right I thought that
the risk of not saying something about
it far outweighed the risk of saying
something about it and so I said
something about it but I don't think you
can do that you see this is also why
it's so useful to really deeply
understand that in some sense that
you're doomed and that life is suffering
you have to understand that and you
think well that's a horrible thing to
understand it's like yeah it's true
though but so like it or not there it is
but there's an advantage to
understanding it because it kind of
frees you up because then you know that
sometimes you don't have a path that
isn't without catastrophe but you still
can choose the paths and that looks like
bravery like I don't really think it is
in some sense maybe it is it's just that
for me I picked the path that was gonna
cause me less grief as far as I was
concerned and so I also think that you
speak out when to not speak out makes
you resentful and bitter and unless you
want to be resentful and bitter and I
wouldn't recommend that because it's a
it's a it's one of the prime pathways to
hell so to speak and so if you're
resentful it means one of two things you
should grow the hell up and shut up and
get at it and be mature because you're
just whining or you're actually being
subjected to a certain form of tyranny
and unless you want to be a slave you
should stand up and say something about
it and so you also have to decide about
that you have to decide on the
conditions under which you regard your
life is worth living and then you have
to speak up for that and Brent made a
point earlier which is exactly dabbed on
it's like I also so thought the same
thing last year in September it was like
well I can either speak up now when I
can pick the time
place I can pick the matter of an
engagement I can pick the topic or it
can wait five years when this is way
worse I'm much more compromised and the
opportunity might not arise again so
that was an easy choice it's like if
you're gonna fight something that's
growing you might as well fight it when
you're young relatively speaking and
it's small so those are all factors that
you have to take into account so I find
the the missing element in almost every
discussion about human beings and what
they're like and why is development that
we do not appreciate the importance of
developmental environments and we do not
appreciate how long development goes on
for human beings I think because human
beings are so unusual in this regard but
the question of whether or not to speak
up is in some sense not a question if
you've had certain developmental
experiences one of the crucial ones is
that for some reason you have spoken up
and you've lived to tell the tale if you
have that experience then you know
something that other people don't into
it which is how you get from A to B and
feel alright about it
I would also say something is not
analytical about this choice and I don't
know whether this is true in general or
not I do know that people who end up
speaking up and becoming well known
about it become focused on this question
because in some sense we are all
interested in the question of how to get
other people to stand up to so that
society can move in a reasonable
direction but for me the phrase that I
think of is it allows me to sleep at
night if I don't stand up I mean then I
lie there in bed at night and wonder why
I didn't and if I do then even though
things go haywire I feel good and the
point is it doesn't mean that I'm
necessarily going to come out ahead but
it does mean that I'm ok with myself
that I don't have to be angry at myself
for not saying what I know needed to be
said
so anyway I'm sure that comes from early
developmental experience but it doesn't
have to be early you can try it out try
it out on something where you know you
can survive and see what happens and
you'll develop the toolkit I just made I
want to add something because that made
me think of what happened terms of
Jordan is that I knew Jordan before the
whole pronoun thing and I had come to
appreciate him and I guess in my case
the the the thing that prompted me to
speak out was that I saw someone that I
could identify it wasn't an abstract
thing anymore cuz political correctness
is just a very abstract concept that's
floating up in the air and I saw someone
that I could identify that I knew who
was being targeted and so it was
actually how could I like it was the
easiest thing in the world then to say
something because it was like okay it's
happening now here and I can imagine
that I mean I didn't have I'm not in a
university setting so I don't have that
opportunity all the time but it seems
like in both your cases it was also what
was happening it's like it's happening
now I to to to my environment I have to
I have to speak because it's it's it's
my life like it's it's it's there so
yeah Helen asks in order for the concept
of equality to work it must stem from
the idea that everybody on earth has the
same value / dignity regardless of
lineage talents beliefs or status how
can we convince ourselves of our own
Worth and thus influence others to see
their own worth as discovering one's
dignity is an inside job
easy question
yeah this is this I think is another one
of these that has a little bit of a
bitter pill to it because I actually do
function on the principle that all
people are effectively equal that there
might be tiny little differences between
populations and that one day we might
ultimately know what they mean this is
certainly not true athletically by the
way different populations are good at
different things because different
habitats select for different things but
that's not true of the cognitive
capacity and the moral capacity those
things are effectively selected for
universally the bitter pill part is that
effectively we are all equal at birth
what happens to us after separates us
out and it seems to me that it is
essential that we actually provide
everybody with an environment that is
enriching and allows them to develop
full capacity and then they can sort
themselves out based on how they decide
to spend their their time and effort but
I do think at least as a as a working
premise imagining that all people no
matter where they're from no matter what
population they belong to have equal
capacity and given enriching
environments will attain the ability to
do things that are very rarely seen
because most of our environments really
aren't as enriching as they might be
so I don't know how but this one's typed
so whoever did that I'm from Montreal
although I've been in Vancouver for more
than two years now I still follow the
news over there from time to time and I
was wondering what were your thoughts on
Bill 62 which the Quebec government
calls an act to foster adherence to
state religious neutrality and in
particular to provide a frame in
framework for religious accommodation
requests in certain bodies so for those
who are not familiar with it here's what
you need to know here's an excerpt of
the bill personnel members of bodies and
public services must exercise their
functions with their face uncovered
unless they have to cover their face in
particular because of their working
conditions or because of Occupational or
task related requirements
similarly persons receiving services
from such personnel members much must
have their face uncovered so the fear
here is that this bill only targets
Muslim women who wear the niqab this
vision of a secular society is closer to
what the French have in France and it's
often perceived as latent racism in the
rest of Canada of course the libertarian
side of me doesn't want the government
to tell anyone what they can or cannot
wear but at the same time I recognize
that the niqab is a symbol of oppression
and it carries value values that are
contrary to those of our society how do
you reconcile the two is it okay to
force freedom on people with laws that
in a way restrict that same freedom
I can't answer that probably because I
haven't thought about it enough I mean I
can see like my gut tendency is that
it's a bad idea I would say I think
probably because it it expands
government power in a manner that is
likely to be counterproductive in the
medium to long term that's how I feel
about it I understand why the French do
it in France and why they're following
that example in Quebec you know it's and
it it's not obvious that everybody who's
wearing the niqab is doing it by choice
but it isn't clear to me that the
government attempt to restrict that is
going to cause more good than harm we'll
see right we have a chance to watch it
unfold because it's happening in Quebec
it's an experiment of sorts
we can watch it unfold we can gather
some information time will tell I
suppose yeah well I guess I'm to
québécois I don't have I don't have a
solution for that question I think that
I do have a thought and I have a thought
about what our societies are kind of
based on and I think that one of the the
idea of the face of encountering
someone's face it's it's a very very
deep part of what our world is based on
because it has to do with trust has to
do with this this capacity to encounter
people and so the whole idea of a
democracy or a free society has to do
with that capacity to encounter someone
and and so I think that the niqab like
veil I don't like I've never I've never
mind like veiled people but my the first
time that I encountered a woman in niqab
it was very odd because it it is my
first reaction it's not even thought out
but like my
to ative reaction is that it's difficult
to see that that's a person and I know
she's I know it is obviously I know it's
a person but the the grammar that we use
like that that Western society is used
for ever to to to know that you're
interacting with someone is not there
and so I can understand the the
difficulty with especially the face
covering I can understand the difficulty
that that society is trying to figure
out like how do we do this how do in a
society that's based on on trust an
automatic trust right that's our society
is based on automatic trust the first
reaction you have to someone when you
meet them on the street is to trust them
and I've lived in places where that is
absolutely not the case
and so it's for me it's a it's a it's a
question like I don't necessarily think
like Jordan said I think that I either
live in Quebec and I know how
left-leaning
the Quebec government is and how it
loves to really put its fingers down
into people's private lives and so I
also have a tendency in myself to to say
back off but I think I was a bigger
question in terms of of our be like kind
of essential values I think it's it's
something that has to be played out and
like Jordan said we'll see how it plays
out you have said dr. Peterson that
there is absolutely no connection
between IQ and wisdom or being a good
person has there ever been an effort by
psychologists to quantitatively measure
wisdom and if so what is its relation to
life success happiness etc yeah all
right well the best way the best we can
do is is measure the big five an IQ and
after that it's pretty sketchy from a
from a personality or psychometric
perspective and I mean my own sense is
that I mean people get more
conscientious and more agreeable and
more emotionally stable as they get
older and so that might be part of what
constitutes wisdom we've also been sort
of investigating the hypothesis that
part of wisdom might be you know imagine
that you're an introvert
but that you learn the skills of an
extrovert so you sort of expand your
toolkit of adaptation and that you're a
nun conscientious person so you know how
to relax but you learn how to discipline
yourself you know I think you can expand
your your your bag of tricks and then
match your behavior more specifically to
the situational demands in an
appropriate way and that's something
like wisdom but we're a long way from
being able to to quantify it and people
have tried you know and they've tried to
quantify well-being it's something that
Sam Harris really is he's an advocate of
that approach oh I'm extraordinarily
skeptical about it I think the
psychometrics are dismal but we're not
wise enough to quantify wisdom I'm
really surprised I've heard you say this
about the lack of relationship between
intelligence and wisdom and I'm not
surprised that they aren't the same
thing but I am surprised to hear you say
there's no relationship at all I mean it
seems like at least very low
intelligence probably results in the
failure of wisdom to emerge is that not
true in your experience no I wouldn't
say that I mean I've seen some I could
tell you a story all right I'll tell you
a story so I had this client years ago
many many years ago who basically
presented herself like a street person
she wore pretty dirty clothing and she
was pretty unkempt and she was
unbelievably shy like she couldn't
approach a person without going like
this like bowing down literally and
going like this it was like there was a
light emanating from the people that she
was approaching and she couldn't bear it
and she had come to this unit on a
mental hospital grounds that I was
working on and nobody had actually
really listened to her when she came
into the unit and I was assigned to
teach her more pro-social behavior
because the way that she approached
people
was well obviously quite strange and so
people were reacting to her in a
somewhat negative way but I actually
listened to her and I tried that for a
while but then I listened to her and it
turned out that she had been in the
hospital and at that point the hospital
had emptied itself of most of its
residents and the only people left in
the hospital were people who were so
ruined that you cannot even conceive of
it the hospital at that point is quite
an old hospital about the size of
University that had tunnels underneath
it connecting the buildings so that
people didn't freeze to death in that
cold Canadian winters and many of the
residents of the asylum were down there
and they were it was like walking
through down T's Inferno or painting by
Hieronymus Bosch or a collection of
photographs by Diane Arbus like it was
seriously disturbing and strange and
those were the people left in the
hospital and she'd been an inpatient
from time to time but she well I can
tell you some more things about her she
she wasn't very bright
she wasn't educated she wasn't very
attractive she wasn't skilled in the
world and she had she lived at home and
she had an alcoholic boyfriend who was
schizophrenic and was always muddling
her head with satanic delusions and I
think it was her aunt was dying at home
and like man on every dimension of life
quality and potential she was in the low
percentiles you know and when I listened
to her she told me a story about this
dog she had she's taking this dog out
for a walk and she liked this dog and
she was pretty good at taking care of it
and then she had this idea she'd been
released from the hospital and was holy
and then was seeing was an outpatient
instead of an inpatient and she'd
actually come to the hospital to find an
administrator who would listen to her
because she had an idea and she couldn't
really distinguish between the
administrators and the psychologists as
far as they were
she was concerned they were all high
status people they're just all the same
and so we weren't really the right
people to even be
talking to but her she had conjured up
this idea and the idea was I could take
this dog and I could go get one of those
inpatients and I could take the
inpatient for a walk at the same time
that I walked my dog and that would be
good for them and I thought she just
blew me away
it's like this woman she just had she
had a rough life man like it was rough
and despite the fact that it was rough
and despite the fact that she was not as
an intelligent person in the
psychometric sense and that she had
virtually no advantages that were
detectable she was able to look outside
herself and generate this act of
kindness that really required her to go
out of her way and pursue it to you know
in against him superable odds in some
sense given how unbelievably shy she was
and that was one of the first times that
I came to understand that if there was a
relationship between intelligence and
wisdom there wasn't much of one and the
other thing I've noticed among my
clients is that well among the people
that I've dealt with is that it's very
often that intelligence allows you to
drive yourself crazy and unbelievably
creative and and manipulative ways like
it's it's quite common for psychologists
to experience a phenomena where the
intelligent client who's having mental
trouble is in much more trouble than the
less intelligent client because well
first they're arrogant and second they
can argue like mad for for the validity
of their pathology let's say even though
they know perfectly well that it's
destroying their life and so I really do
think they're they're not they're not
self-evidently related so that's that's
been my thought and experience anyway so
as someone who is very soft-spoken and
nervous about speaking up I found myself
falling into the position of tool of
sjw's I have taken the steps to leave
however friends and people who I know
are good well-meaning people are
becoming for lack of a better word
radicalized or encouraged to violence
and bully tactics
how could I approach these people who
still think I'm a member of their group
to at the very least to reevaluate their
positions or take steps to leave also is
it even my place to try to help them
leave to all thanks here's the key I
think the SJW program is an unconscious
automatic program the alternative is a
conscious program so what you're up
against is the fact that when people are
on autopilot they're hard to reach the
thing that causes the mind to become
conscious to invest in this expensive
way of processing things rather than to
continue on autopilot is error that is
to say when you detect an error it wakes
you up so I don't know how much hope
there is it really depends on the
individual you're talking to but the
best hope you've got is to attempt to
cause them to see contradictions in what
they're saying when they detect that
they are generating an error they will
have to wake up in order to reconcile
them as I mentioned in my talk it's
difficult because they've got this
hermetically sealed set of beliefs that
have an answer for everything but if you
can somehow detect a fissure in that
thing and exploit it to get them to see
that they are making a logical error
they will have to wake up to answer you
and then you can talk to them
consciously I would say prepare yourself
to leave and partly do that by trying to
think about what your life would be like
if you don't leave because it's gonna be
hard to leave but obviously you've
decided that it's going to be hard or
impossible to stay so you're in one of
those situations where you know you've
got a choice between two poisons pick
the healthier one and then I would say
if someone asks you why you're leaving
tell them but don't tell them to
convince them because if you tell them
to convince them you won't you'll just
raise these defenses that Brett referred
to you just tell them what motivated
your decision and you really have to be
neutral and detached about it
and they might listen if they don't
listen shut up that's it took me a long
time to learn the meaning of the
biblical injunction to not cast pearls
before swine it's a very harsh
injunction and it's very apropos to this
situation that you're in if someone is
not listening to what you say when
you're doing your best to delineate out
a truth then you violate the truth by
continuing to delineate it you're not
where you think you are just back off
shut down because they're not ready to
hear the message and Carl Rogers for
example the great clinician he regard he
thought that there were prerequisites to
to successful psychotherapy that the
psychotherapist him or herself couldn't
induce and one of those was that the
person who is seeking psychotherapeutic
change had to be ready to change you
couldn't take someone who was ready to
wasn't ready to change and use
psychotherapy to get them ready to
change they had to already have
encountered that error that that
indicated to them that in some manner
the jig was up and they needed to learn
something and if you're talking to
someone who thinks that they have
everything tied up and they've already
got all the answers then all you do is
sully your your words by continuing to
share them it's harsh but that's how it
is muster up your courage take the
pathway that you think will be least
harmful to you and if you're questioned
say why but don't try to convince
anybody because all it'll do is raise
their defenses now the the fact of you
leaving that's actually a pretty strong
argument so you're doing
you've got your argument best formulated
in terms of your actual action and that
could easily be sufficient so and the
probability that some people who are
doubtful will be curious and ask you is
high so you then you also want to have
your story straight you want to figure
out what it is really deeply truly that
tipped you in the direction of this
that this was a bad idea and then you
can share that with them and you share
it as like a fallible person who isn't
certain that this is the right thing to
do but that you're willing to risk it
and maybe the part of the other person
that isn't completely possessed by the
ideological slogan will be awake enough
to listen but that's really all you can
do so how do counselors break through
the victim mentality when clients find
power and this identity
well first of all they often don't find
power in that identity like if they're
if they've come to therapy for example
they know that something's up what I
what I usually do when people are
adopting a victim stance is to explore
is to ask the person why it is that they
construe the situation in that manner
you know so first of all it's very
individual thing right so there's no
cookie cutter answer you you want to
find out I mean first of all the person
might have been victimized there's a
high probability I mean most people are
victimized at some point in their life
in some serious way and so you don't let
that unpack itself and then and then you
got to ask the person well what do they
want like how do they view themselves in
the future and and they have to kind of
build an ideal that they're aiming for
and generally if you let people think
through the idea of the ideal that
they're aiming for like cringing victim
is not what comes out like they may have
learned that that's the only card they
have to play but that's usually a fairly
easy thing to fix because you can you
can use assertiveness training
techniques you know speaking in a
low-resolution manner to help people
learn how to stand up for themselves and
you do that basically and this is sort
of relevant to the issue that everybody
asks about to begin with is like how do
you know when to stand up for yourself I
mean one way of figuring that out is
like maybe you're not ready to take on a
political battle in fact you're probably
not I would say like do that at your
peril but you might be willing to say
one thing to someone who's pushing you a
little bit too hard you know after
thinking about it for a while that would
tilt that relationship away from the
tyrant slave axis you know because
you'll walk away Brett said well
sometimes you don't say something then
you can't sleep at night and when you're
not sleeping you're thinking about all
the things you should have said because
that's what happens when you sleep like
that because you've sort of violated
yourself in a sense and you know if you
walk away from an exchange and you're
feeling resentful and all these
potential responses are going through
your head
then you kind of you sort through those
responses and you think well is there
one of those things that I could tone
down a little bit and then actually say
to this person and usually you'll find
something so you sort of progress
towards that kind of courage in in
increments and that's fine like the the
trajectory you're on is more important
than the position you're in and so if
you want to take on the tyranny of the
world let's say you start by addressing
a problem that's bothering you and
making you feel resentful that you
actually could take on like maybe
there's something you need to say to
your brother or your sister or your boss
or an employee you know because they're
taking advantage of you in some way
that's making you resentful and you
think well what do I want how would I
rather have this be and then is there
some small thing that I would be willing
to do that would tap it in that
direction and you know that that almost
always works it certainly encourages you
and embolden you and and well encourages
you in the technical way which is that
it makes you more courageous and so you
you start but you start speaking up
let's say or you start telling the truth
partly by not lying that's really
helpful but you also start telling the
truth by taking small risks of a size
that you can actually manage and you
develop the expertise in doing that you
know you don't want to like if you're
gonna be a good person you don't walk
this down the street and pick up the
first homeless person that you see and
take them home it's like that's not
gonna work you just don't have the
ability to do that you are not in any
position to manage that it's gonna be a
catastrophe and it's the same with
taking on major ethical battles it's
like well start with some of the smaller
ethical battles and you build up some
muscles you know develop some expertise
and everyone knows you you sit down and
think to yourself for a bit everybody
knows that there's someone to whom they
should say something that they're not
saying you know and and then you want to
say that with minimal necessary force
something like that and and you want to
do it at the right time and that'll
that'll make you a little taller
your own eyes and that's a good thing
maybe you'll even stand up a little
straighter that's a good thing it'll put
you on the right trajectory and and then
at some point you might be able to be
take on like a major battle without
getting crushed by it so given that
intelligence and conscientiousness are
the two biggest predictors of success in
life what advice do you have for someone
in the 99th percentile and one and the
first percentile and the other asking
for a friend
well I would say look at your other
traits you know first percentile and
conscientiousness is pretty rough first
percentile in intelligence you wouldn't
be taking the test so I'm assuming it's
first percentile in conscientiousness
it's like first you're probably young
people get more conscientious as they
get older it's gonna be a problem no
matter what you do so you've got to
learn to discipline yourself it's very
very difficult but you know you might be
very high and trade openness for example
which means you're gonna you're gonna
involve yourself in creative pursuits
and the interest that's generated by the
creative pursuit might be sufficient to
keep you on task while you're engaged in
the creative act independently of
whether or not you're conscientious like
there's many forms of motivation right
and so most stand-up comedians aren't
very conscientious like that's not a
lifestyle you could have if you're
conscientious most rock musicians aren't
very conscientious because for what for
the same reason conscientious people
can't tolerate that deviant routine it
just drives them crazy so I would say
look at your other traits and see if
there are some strengths but you know
might not be a bad idea to make a life
plan and try to work on the discipline
because first percentile is you know
it's gonna cause you trouble we have
seen an increase in political
polarization and identity politics /
tribalism in modern political culture my
question is what do you believe is
causing this and how can we go back from
this so I think this is a really
interesting and important point
the the issue is that we human beings
are built for an oscillation between
boom-and-bust circumstances and in a
boom we experienced what economists
would call growth and when things are
growing you can afford to be decent to
other people when you reach a point of
austerity what happens is tribalism
breaks out because the way to deal with
what is effectively an addiction to
growth that we have when the growth runs
out is to generate pseudo growth by
figuring out who can't defend what they
have and going after it and this is the
thing that has caused the worst
atrocities in history and the task for
us is to realize that the increase in
polarization and tribalism at the moment
is actually something we should expect
it happens at this point in history and
the trick for us is to figure out how to
break this boom and bust oscillation so
that we are not repeatedly exposed to
these extremely dangerous outbreaks of
tribalism
well I I I don't know I I don't I think
I agree but I I there's another move in
history and a move and and there is a
move in history which is that when
certain civilizations become actually
quite wealthy and quite content they
tend to fragment because they they have
everything they need we saw that you
know in the in the late Roman Empire and
it's as if they lose they lose the
capacity for their own cohesion and when
that happens those who are tribal can
come in and Ram through that that like
kind of weakened civilization and just
like and I sort of bust through it and
so to me I get the sense that the the
increased polarization in in our society
is that it's not just polarization I
think there's also just a basic
fragmentation and and and that
fragmentation is is almost physically
real its physical even in the manner in
which we develop our are the layout of
houses and the layout of like of
suburbian neighborhoods where we don't
like I've been in my neighborhood for 15
years and I barely know my neighbors and
I think most people in North America
have that same experience it's like we
are we are like a are the tissue that
the mesh that's that created whatever it
is that we are like whatever
civilization whatever is is is is
fragmenting and so I think that that's
one of the thing that is causing the
chaos at least and those and the problem
is that those some people who see that
fragmenting they're afraid and they then
they want to pull back and say okay we
need to get something really straight
something really hard and then they they
they tend to go towards tribalism you
know it's like it's beyond like the
economic mean I think that the economic
the economic thing can can kind of
unleash it but if you look at
by Maya Germany and you look at where we
are now the the the social tendencies in
like the the kind of underlying feeling
that things are falling apart were there
too and then a so then an economic
disaster created that crazy kind of so I
think there's a there's a there's a
quite a quite a few level of things
happening at the same time I think I
think we don't exactly know what's
causing the polarization I I think that
you could attribute it to some degree to
rising levels of inequality that might
be particularly true in the US but the
polarization is also occurring in Europe
and it's also occurring to a lesser
degree in Canada so I think it's
something inequality is no trivial thing
and it has profound effects but I think
there's other things going on as well we
we don't know the role that social media
plays like I do think that it's working
as an amplifier you know you you now
hear about every idiot thing the left
radical left does right instantly and
you hear every idiot thing the radical
right does too and I think it radically
distorts your perception of how unstable
the world is like you know one of the
things that was really interesting over
the last two or three decades is that
crime took a nosedive in a major way at
exactly the same time that the incidence
of crime reporting in the news climbed
to new heights and so people are
convinced we're convinced well even now
that things are far more dangerous than
they have ever been ever and that's not
true like general civil society is safer
than it's been since 1962 and in 1962 it
was basically safer than it's ever been
ever in the history of the world and so
the media that were the information
matrix that we're looking at the world
through isn't giving us an accurate
sample of what's out there and I think
that that and I can see this to some
degree when I'm when I'm looking at
Twitter
is that I get a feed of outrageous
things that are happening on campus it's
like how god there's hundreds of
colleges and universities and at any
given time the probability that someone
is doing something that's stupid in a
newsworthy fashion is like a hundred
percent and in in any reasonable society
basically I'd never know about it and so
then I'd have to sample the environment
that's right around me which actually
turns out to be pretty damn stable like
at the University of Toronto the
proportion of people who are committed
and Tifa type radicals is like none it's
one in a thousand maybe or maybe maybe
it's one in 500 but we're looking at the
world through this mediated perceptual
structure and it isn't clear that it's
giving us unbiased information so please
tell us how we can tell the difference
between misguided SJW types versus the
people with evil intent yeah that's an
interesting question I will say
empirically I don't think it's all that
difficult I think they sound very
different and I think maybe the approach
is to ask questions if you ask questions
of a misguided person who's going along
with something based on the label on the
box rather than the contents of the box
then they will tend to say more
reasonable things about why it is that
they are doing what they are doing if
you question it in other words they will
defend some version of equity that's
actually recognizable as a type of
equality rather than some undefinable
booby-trap that's been set for you in
general the the hardcore bad actors are
pretty few and far between and
unfortunately it doesn't take very many
many of them to set something like this
in motion but for the most part the
movement is composed of people who are
misguided at one level or another
and people who are cynical are small in
number but important in effect I think
that one of the ways you can tell is
that you can actually have a
conversation with someone who's
misguided let's say if you you know if
you start the conversation properly you
can ask them questions and they'll
engage and you know with a bit of care
you can actually start to talk but
someone who's malevolent it's like you
can just forget about that that's not
getting off the ground because that just
undermines the game that they're playing
and so if if despite your genuine
goodwill you can't find the human being
underneath the ideology then it's best
to back away and you know in the
McMaster see you some of you have seen
the video at McMaster University where I
was completely shouted down essentially
with air horns and chants and all of
that most of those people in there
they're just dopey kids fundamentally
you know and and their idiot professors
had used them as avatars for their
pathetic ideology and you know I think
while they're 19 years old what the hell
do they know if you met them in in a pub
like 20 minutes later they'd be chirping
away in a perfectly reasonable manner
like your neighbor's kid you know but
not everyone in the crowd was like that
you know and it's the feminists men are
the ones I really worry about often
especially the bigger guys because I'm
not sure what game they're playing but
I've seen a couple of the same suspects
at a number of different protests and I
can tell they've got blank eyes and
they're just looking for trouble like
there are there are people I would avoid
on the street I can I can see them and
there's no haven't come there's no
having a conversation with those people
like in fact the mere fact that you
would like to have a conversation with
them
is enough to demonstrate that you're
their enemy because they don't want to
be moved away from their their
manipulative grip on route to power it's
something like that so so dr. Weinstein
he came here looking for a fight mr.
posh I made a response video to to
something you said in the Joe Rogan
experience do you have anything to say
I'm glad you're asking that I was hoping
it would come up so I don't know how
many people have seen the video and what
it's responding to but the short version
is that I said something on the Joe
Rogan podcast about there being
different kinds of truth that I argued
for something I call metaphorical truth
that something can be literally false
but it can contain wisdom and the way
you know is that if you act as if it
were true you come out ahead of where
you would if you act according to the
fact that it's false and I then said
that scientific truth is the top truth
in the hierarchy and the response was
that it was arrogant of me to say that
there was a top truth that you know
effectively from what position do I do
that and yeah I can you want to go ahead
I just want to say that's not the
argument the argument is that there was
a performative contradiction in your in
your statement because you talked you
said that factual truth is higher than
metaphorical truth but then to say that
there's a top-level truth or that
there's an overarching truth is to use a
metaphorical structure to to demonstrate
where you're placing your truth and so
within the statement there was a car
there as a performative contradiction in
terms of you have to resort to
metaphorical truth to speak of hierarchy
because all the language of hierarchy is
metaphorical and therefore to place
factual truth at the top of that
hierarchy is a performative
contradiction so that's my argument so I
will I will plead guilty to using
metaphor to
defend my position because of course
language is composed of metaphors both
living and dead and it's really hard to
communicate anything without running
afoul of that standard but I will defend
in spite of that guilt I will defend the
idea that scientific truth is the top
truth in the hierarchy and the reason is
really simple it's because there is no
mechanism for sorting between
metaphorical truths that belong to
different traditions and are in conflict
with each other so in other words if we
take to like behave well when you die
you go to heaven that's cool you should
do that on the other hand if you behave
well in Brahman Atman system you may be
reincarnated as something better than
you are now
that's also cool but it's not the same
truth right so you can't sort out these
are both kinds of wisdom and I think we
know exactly what kind of wisdom they
are or at least we should which is if
you behave so as to be reincarnated as
something better or to go to heaven what
it will do is in all probability it will
leave your descendants really well
positioned in their in their culture and
that means that your genes which you
might not have been in a position to say
anything about will be well positioned
to persist and spread because your
descendants will be well placed so in
effect going to heaven or being
reincarnated as something better than
you were our stand-ins for a genetic
truth that we can't say and so what I'm
arguing is that what makes the
scientific truth hierarchically superior
is that it explains all the subordinate
truths in a way that is logically
consistent whereas if you were to
prioritize heaven as a truth then you
would have to say well reincarnation is
therefore false or you would have to
have them all simultaneously be true in
some unreconciled l'ile way so the only
one that has the special characteristic
of accounting for all the others is the
scientific truth okay so I'm gonna get
into this now so I think that what you
just did was nested your claim for the
validity of scientific truth within a
pragmatic Four
work which is what I claimed when I was
talking to Sam Harris was necessary
because you said I believe that the
justification for for assuming the truth
of the of the of the mythological
representation was its effect on on
something that's associated with a
Darwinian process right and that's how
you used that's how what you used to
justify your claim that it was in fact
true so in the discussion that you're
referencing my point
so my point was essentially that there
is something called metaphorical truth
and that it's a real thing so I was I'm
in agreement with you on that where we
might be in disagreement is that there
is simultaneously a thing that I would
call literal truth or scientific truth
and by the way I'm not saying that what
scientists say is in this category
inherently scientists can be wrong but
the point is truth that is
scientifically verifiable that makes
predictions has a special priority in
this hierarchy because it is the one
objective version it is not contingent
on being nested in another in a series
of beliefs so what if it's a scientific
truth that's metaphorically wrong oh and
they're like I can give you an example
okay so I read this the memoirs of a KGB
scientist KGB agent who worked with the
Russians in this biochemical lab and
their job was to meld Ebola with
smallpox because smallpox is Ebola is
not that contagious and so that's kind
of annoying if you're trying to kill
people whereas smallpox but it's really
fatal whereas smallpox is really
contagious so if you could get the two
together and then develop an aerosol
spray you could kill a lot of people and
in fact they did kill about five hundred
Russians by mistake when some of what
they were doing escaped but it isn't
obvious to me that that's an invalid
scientific pursuit but I do think that
it's an invalid ethical pursuit and so
that seems to me to indicate that the
ethical pursuit supersedes the
scientific pursuit with regards to truth
clay
so I'm gonna disagree with you I would
say it doesn't supersede with respect to
the truth claim it supersedes with
respect to considerations of behavior
and policy so I absolutely agree with
you there are plenty of scientific
truths that are deeply unfortunate and I
want to take what you said the first
thing that you said okay if you are good
you die and you go to heaven if you're
good you die and you're reincarnated as
a higher being those two things are the
same okay in terms of their effect
there are restating of the hierarchy the
hierarchy religion is all about the
hierarchy that's what religion is about
the the restating of the hierarchy in
those two terms have the same effect in
terms of what we're saying is that if
you're good you will not meld those two
things together and that is the
hierarchy the hierarchy itself is the
capacity to be above quantitative purely
quantitative considerations and to apply
qualitative thinking and the whole
language of hierarchy is all a language
about a movement from from quantity up
to quality like that it's its movement
it's about going up a mountain it's
going up the base and then going up to
you to unity and when you stand in that
top place then you can look down and you
can judge what facts because there are
there is an innumerable amounts of fact
there's an infinite quantity of facts
you can decide which facts are worth
pursuing and so that's what religion is
and that's what the hierarchy is so if
you take if you take qualitative if you
take a quantitative tidbit of
information and you say that is above
let's say qualitative judgment how do
you even why why are you even focusing
on that quantitative data because
there's there's an in
infinite amount of them so you have to
have a matte manner by which you focus
on something and that is the hierarchy
and that is the whole language of of the
religious hierarchy so so what do you do
where religious traditions and what I'm
calling metaphorical Truths conflict so
let's say mating systems I would argue
that monogamy is a superior mating
system because it does not sideline any
significant population of males
if you sideline a significant population
of males by having what biologists would
call a polygynous system or people would
generally call a polygamous system if
you do that then you have sexually
frustrated males who are left over and
inevitably become something like a
marauding horde or an army or something
immoral like that now wait wait now
you're assuming that's bad yeah and so
you're falling into Jonathan's trap
because you're saying you see you have
this a priori framework that monogamy is
better because you've already decided
what constitutes bad you can't help but
lay a moral framework over your
selection of facts and so that I mean
I'm not trying to trap you I know this
is a crazily complicated problem yeah
but but the idea that you that that the
fundamental idea is that you can't
select the damn facts and order them
which you have to do you have to do it
without applying an a priori moral
framework right so I would say I am
applying an a priori moral framework I
am NOT treating this as us I mean you
know we could also look at the behavior
of people as a physical process it's
equally a physical process as it is a
moral behavioral process I'm not doing
that I'm being a human being and I'm
saying from the point of view of values
that probably everybody in this room
would share it is not desirable to have
sexually frustrated young men roving
around being violent because they can't
find a mate because some other
highly-placed males in the society have
many mates that's not a good thing
that's not me speaking factually that's
me speaking morally but my point my
point is not that that's what should
come out of this conversation my point
is different religions that contain
metaphorical
throughs differ over what a viable
reproductive strategy is in other words
Christianity prioritizes monogamy modern
Judaism does too but the Torah does not
so okay so okay so your claim is that
because it's very difficult to
adjudicate between competing moral
systems that science is preferable with
regards to truth claims because there's
a way of adjudicating between scientific
truths but I would say the mere fact
that it's difficult to adjudicate
between competing moral claims doesn't
indicate therefore that science is a
higher truth it just indicates that
science has an advantage when it comes
to comparison that ethical systems don't
it doesn't means that ethical systems
are perfect
no no so this is one of these places
where I don't exactly know what I'm
running afoul of and why I think my
brain is built around some sort of model
that makes it hard for me to understand
why we could possibly be disagreeing
over this my point is you have a
thousand different belief systems
they're all built out of metaphorical
truths in a certain amount of real truth
let's just stick science in with the
rest of them it's it's belief system a
thousand and one okay now let's say well
which of these is best how are you even
going to do that there's only one of
them that has a distinct characteristic
its number a thousand and one what's its
distinct characteristic it explains why
all the others work so how is it not
just by virtue of the fact that it does
something that nothing else can how is
it not the top one in the hierarchy
we have run a little bit past eight
would we would you all want to which
i'll be interested in getting together
for a an organized debate like a little
tag team Peterson patch out versus
Weinstein Harris sure okay
that's a good place to end so
[Music]
[Applause]
um that's it so we have the reception
I'll explain the yeah explain the stuff
about the reception now it's at 11:28
west hastings you go up Erard until you
get to west hastings you take a ripe and
it's like two blocks up on your left
it's a five-minute walk
got room for like a hundred people so
you know first-come first-serve I
suppose free food not free drinks but
I'll be worth it and yeah that's it so
thank you all very very very much for
coming we really appreciate it and have
a good night